[Music]  welcome back to top corn chef Gary  Justin congratulations for making it  this far but there can be only one top  dorm chef each of you has 20 minutes to  create a meal from the ingredients in  the backpack  are you ready you may open your  backpacks  the ingredients are ramen noodles and  water when I saw the ingredients I was a  little nervous because I've only made  chicken flavored ramen and this was beef  I don't eat ramen noodles I can't have  gluten  two minutes Justin is way behind  he hasn't even heated up his water carry  this really is top ramen really  delicious great dorm food too bad it  wasn't enough  Justin this was inspired I didn't think  you could do  I made a bond  [Applause]